CHRIS?
>> Chris: MIKE, THANK YOU.
>> SURE.
>> Chris: MINNESOTA FRESHMAN
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR MAY
BE IN STILL MORE TROUBLE
AFTER FELLOW DEMOCRATS READ
HER LATEST COMMENTS ON THE
POLITICO WEBSITE.
OMAR SAYS THE HOPE AND
CHANGE OFFERED BY BARACK
OBAMA WAS A MIRAGE.
RECALLING THE CAGING OF KIDS
AT THE BORDER AND THE
DRONING OF COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD BOTH ON
MR. OBAMA'S WATCH SHE SAYS
HE OPERATED WITHIN THE SAME
BROKEN FRAMEWORK AS HIS
REPUBLICAN SUCCESSOR.
QUOTE:  WE CAN'T BE ONLY
UPSET WITH TRUMP.
HIS POLICIES ARE BAD BUT
MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO CAME
BEFORE HIM ALSO HAD REALLY
BAD POLICIES.
THEY JUST WERE MORE POLISHED
THAN HE WAS.
WE DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO GET
AWAY WITH MURDER BECAUSE
THEY ARE POLISHED.
WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
ACTUAL POLICIES THAT ARE
BEHIND THE PRETTY FACE AND
THE SMILE.
OMAR RESPONDS ON TWITTER,
QUOTE:  EXHIBIT A OF HOW
REPORTERS DISTORT WORDS.
I HAVE AM AN OBAMA FAN.
I WAS SAYING HOW TRUMP IS
DIFFERENT FROM OBAMA AND WHY
WE SHOULD FOCUS ON POLICY,
NOT POLITICS.
THIS IS WHY I ALWAYS TAPE MY
INTERVIEWS.
SPEAKING OF OMAR AND
OCASIO-CORTEZ, ANOTHER
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN DEAN
PHILLIPS TELLS POLITICO,
QUOTE:  SUDDENLY AN ENTIRE
PARTY IS BEING BRANDED BY